>> Tucker: THE GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN ENDED FOR THE MOMENT,
TEMPORARILY.
BUT THE BATTLE OVER A BORDER
WALL CONTINUES.
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE NANCY
PELOSI VOWED SHE WILL NEVER
FUND THAT WALL UNDER ANY
CIRCUMSTANCES.
THE PRESIDENT PROMISES HE IS
GOING TO BUILD ONE.
SO THAT SEEMS TO LEAVE THE
WHITE HOUSE WITH ONE OPTION.
DECLARE A NATIONAL EMERGENCY
AND ORDER THE BUILDING OF A
WALL ON THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE A PRETTY
RADICAL SOLUTION.
BUT IS IT?
IT TURNS OUT NATIONAL
EMERGENCIES HAPPEN ALL THE
TIME.
SOMEHOW VERY FEW OF THEM
RECEIVE ANY ATTENTION AT ALL.
IN 1976, CONGRESS PASSED THE
NATIONAL EMERGENCIES ACT.
THAT LAW GRANTS THE PRESIDENT
THE POWER TO DECLARE A STATE
OF EMERGENCY IN RESPONSE TO
VIRTUALLY ANYTHING IF HE
THINKS IT'S NECESSARY.
NATIONAL EMERGENCIES CAN BE
RENEWED ANNUALLY AND ROUTINELY
ARE.
CONGRESS CAN ONLY BLOCK THE
EMERGENCY WITH TWO-THIRD VOTE.
BROAD LAW AND APPLIED A LOT.
IT BEGAN IN 1979 WHEN
PRESIDENT JIMMY CARTER
DECLARED NATIONAL EMERGENCY TO
KEEP THE IRANIAN GOVERNMENT
PROPERTY ENTERING THE UNITED
STATES.
THAT EMERGENCY IS STILL
ONGOING DESPITE BEING OLDER
THAN ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ
FOR EXAMPLE.
SINCE THAT DATE, AMERICAN
PRESIDENTS DECLARED NO FEWER
THAN 58 NATIONAL EMERGENCIES.
31 OF THEM ARE STILL ONGOING.
THE AVERAGE STATE OF EMERGENCY
IN THE COUNTRY LASTED NINE AND
A HALF YEARS.
WHAT ARE THE ENERGIES?
SOME REALLY WERE EMERGENCIES.
SEPTEMBER 2001.
PRESIDENT BUSH ANNOUNCED STATE
OF EMERGENCY TO GIVE WHITE
HOUSE GREATER AUTHORITY TO
MOBILIZE THE MILITARY, CALL
THE NATIONAL GUARD AND PERFORM
COUNTERTERRORIST ACTION.
IT'S BEEN RENEWED EACH OF THE
PAST 18 YEARS.
SO THAT WAS REAL.
WE ALSO HAD A DECADE LONG
NATIONAL EMERGENCY TO COMBAT
THE SWINE FLU.
PRESIDENT TRUMP DECLARED THREE
NATIONAL EMERGENCIES ALREADY.
I BET YOU DIDN'T KNOW THAT.
ONE OF THEM SANCTIONED THOSE
WHO USED SOCIAL MEDIA TO
INFLUENCE ELECTIONS.
THE DASTARDLY MASS DONIANS --
MACEDONIANS.
ANOTHER NATIONAL EMERGENCY
PUNISHES ANYONE WHO WORKS TO
"UNDER MINE SOVEREIGNTY OF
LEBANON.
YOU SEE THE POINT HERE?
IN WASHINGTON, PROTECTING THE
SOVEREIGNTY OF THE FAR AWAY
MIDDLE EASTERN COUNTRY VERY
FEW AMERICANS WILL EVER GO TO
QUALIFIES AS A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY.
PROTECTING OUR OWN COUNTRY
SOVEREIGNTY IS, "IMMORAL."
WE ARE NOT OVERSTATING THAT.
JUST THIS WEEK, FOUR FRESHMEN
DEMOCRATS IN THE HOUSE
COSIGNED LETTER TO DEMAND
LOWER FUNDING FOR THE BORDER
ENFORCEMENT.